[Music]
everyone welcome back to yet another
episode of ETS movies I'm ash province i
am john boone and today we are talking
about the sequel to the 2012 adored by
fans beloved by critics movie from UCP
everyone loves for media and the thing
is for alien covenant you need to know
everything about Prometheus you don't
need to know about a single other alien
movie just for me yet yeah I mean I
think it helps to to know about the
aliens franchise and what helped I don't
think it gives some context to some
things that are happening didn't you say
there is something else that you'll
notice if you watch the Beverly a lien
movies wanted a and believe you said
there was a poll on it Oh lodges
colleges homage homage homage I think
it's over I should comment but maybe
you'll find some homage as too much to
other alien movies so John why don't you
as fast as you can run it down
everything you need to know about from
making your ass ready set go when
Prometheus came out Ridley said that it
wasn't an alien film or wasn't really an
alien film but now we know it is an
alien film especially because it's a
prequel to alien covenant which is a
prequel to alien eventually and so like
a to b to c transitive law we all learn
that in high school we're good okay
so the name of the ship is Prometheus
like in Greek mythology do you know who
promiscuous I'm going to stop the speed
round to test your Greek mythology I
don't know Prometheus's be God that
created all of like mankind and it makes
sense
that's essentially what you need to know
about prometheus is they go looking for
who created mankind which are in these
movies these creatures called the
engineers they're the white giant people
with like the powder that you saw in all
the trailers even though there's only
one of them really in the movie they
find one engineer and then spoiler alert
if you're this far into this explanation
you're not watching Prometheus if you
want go watch Prometheus they find out
that
these engineers created humanity they
sent a spaceship full of a virus to
earth to kill all the people that
spaceship that virus is what was the
beginning of the Xenomorphs that we know
today those are the aliens if you don't
know what a xenomorph is we're backing
up even further so that's essentially
the plot of Prometheus Michael
Fassbender plays a character an Android
named Dave AI wanted Bob it was good
bill I went through every be name I knew
did it come to Dave a lot of Android Bob
anyway David is the only one that
survives the movie along with new Mira
pastas character Elizabeth Chow Shaw
thank you for the assist and they set
off first after all of this horrible
stuff happened for some reason they set
off to still find the engineers planet
that's where the movie and that's where
the prologue alien covenant prologue the
crossing picks up go watch alien
covenant prologue number one because
there's like eight of those prologue and
a million other things on that YouTube
page but the ones you need to watch are
the crossing because otherwise if you
know what happened in Prometheus and
then just go see covenant you're like
how did we get here and then there's
another one called The Last Supper
right which explains James Franco's
presence in alien covenant which is a
little bit bizarre so I mentioned that
the timeline is very confusing you think
you have a master okay let's see so
there's the original alien franchise
that had the for alien movies and then
there was supposed to be a fifth one but
it got cancelled so forget that this one
for now and then they made Prometheus
which we find out is a prequel and then
they made alien covenant which is
getting close so we're getting closer to
alien now and then there might be
another one either in between alien
covenant and alien or an interval
between Prometheus and alien covenant
that was like a talk for a little while
just like it's not a sequel for equality
boy I'm the prequel well there's there's
a prequel there's a sequel but if it's
in between
it's an interval but the sad thing about
that all right great
more alien covenants alien coming into
or whatever ship they're going to name
it after next
no more Sigourney essentially kind of
right now right I mean really got hinted
at it to us that we could see
Ripley again but it seems like how is
there a possibility of Ripley coming
into any of them yeah I've never seen
ever
you never know because I've now evolved
open up the letter came off with
Pandora's box with and out of that all
kinds of things are happening so the
plan was to back end into anyone in
another film that's never going to
happen we've got too much going on so
we'll see how it goes that how we evolve
I'd love to see David and Ripley
I mean that would just be yeah amazing
Ricky's not born yet I know but androids
can live forever
yeah and it also seems like every time
Renly's God gives an interview he kind
of changes what he decides is going to
happen next
it's like heaps of siding mid interview
whether or not he wants to make a people
or a prequel or an interval or a
spin-off or a you're gonna make it or
cohabit other type of that Interpol is a
word but it's it's it is interesting
because so alien five that they were
gonna plan was by Neill Blomkamp that
was a wild presentation I just did on
that but I'm I would have run with that
and reuniting with Sigourney for alien
five some more Ripley and last year at
comic-con when they did the alien
30-year reunion they were still saying
that was going to happen
Sigourney was like scripts great we're
just trying to schedule it right and
then they were like nope cancels not
doing it and then Ridley Scott was like
but I am doing a sequel but it's going
to be too alien covenant and we start
shooting it like in 14 months
that's because I again yeah well I guess
that frees up Sigourney to do
heartbreakers fish I would love a harbor
Kristy that's a records show you guys
want our alien review right now or
should we just talk about her face why
don't we just actually start
brainstorming harder if you mean what
can I reckon I'm Oh now Jennifer Love
Hewitt is married and her daughter needs
to seduce
to lead me to seduce Jason Lee and it
works because all men are dogs
and now she's single again and she's got
to go back in the con because she wants
all Jason's sleeve money somehow to tie
it up in equity I feel like on camera
wise I should be reacting in some way
but I am shook right now that you just a
rattled that all of the time guys so
that is the confusing sort of alien
verse as it stands right now but it was
an entire pitch for Heartbreakers an
entire pitch for Hart burgers she for
some reason
what did you think of ailing government
all right I am only revealing this
because this feels like a safe space
until my crash course recently in the
Alien franchise
I didn't know that much I was kind of
like is it an alien or many aliens and
they just come and I now have all those
answers and I kind of don't care
Hollywood we don't need an origin story
for every single villain in the world
just let us fight some aliens on a
spaceship that's the hill I'm dying on I
just think I think this movie was really
enjoyable to sit through I see why
people that are so invested in it right
it's appointed it's essentially like 30
minutes of the movie passengers and then
an hour of Aelia there is some just like
bizarrely weird crap that happens are we
talking about the exclusively gay moment
eat your heart out Beauty and the bees
Michael Fassbender on Michael Fassbender
hey there's this really weird scene
where fast under one he just fasteners -
how to play a flute flash recorder and
then they kiss and then you start to
getting everyone people are gonna do
what is it it's nothing this is not
hunger steal this is freaking alien
company nothing we have said is a lie it
all happens during this flute play it
would last a bit I actually and I were
flushing each other doing this has been
happening this is happening
I want explanations
from everyone okay we did ask pass under
and release got about it
he's loves challenges so that's a good
challenge how do I play to catch even
how do I fight myself even how do I kiss
myself I think you must do it every
morning the mirror ok another kind of
like what's going on moment was when to
me I was like are these astronauts just
like a bunch of dumb who like walk like
there's walk off casually in like common
people clothes no protection no
breathing apparatus and they just walk
into the atmosphere so I'm sorry but I
hope that I was hoping that everything
was going wrong for them for being so
stupid I would love to do a real quick
rundown of what Ashley has done on this
episode which is MIT pick a movie about
killer aliens it's over there
questionable outfits in the atmosphere
pitched a movie to a sequel to a movie
that came out in 1997 and lusted after
Michael Fassbender but only kissing
Michael fast
well listen I'm I'm all down for in my
in my horror movies for people to be
doing dumb stuff and I'm like why are
you running upstairs and you should be
running outside that whole thing but
like they went outside with no astronaut
suits on maybe there was a scene that
they cut because it was boring as hell
like listening to me could it be a
mansion it could've been about how they
tested that it could have been a simple
line a simple line from Walter you just
wanted like an off screen like 80-yard
Biden being like alien fan but I hope
you got something from the second but
overall I did enjoy it you're going to
enjoy yourself and we will see you next
week if this does not get canceled
before then where we will talk
Heartbreakers cue
[Music]